bonjour merci
en fait vous êtes magnifique de quelques
jours de sa venue répéter cette salade
de ville
et là j'ai commencé à voir la pole
traque j'imagine futurs' on imagine de
trois futures du pire donc j'ai fait
maintenant québécois soit un autre motif
de panique un groupe inconnu plus l'ex
puisse pas dire à tous un produit légal
capestang alors quoi la réalité
j'avais pas quelque chose que la
lamentable avant que vous êtes tout ça
j'en vois ça sarko n'est certain mais
souriant plutôt intelligent parce que
vous êtes une écoute et des belles des
idées et vous allez l'incroyablement
bienveillant et ça se soigne
merci beaucoup donc je voulais vous
présenter quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
compté pour moi rencontrer mon grand
père paul ricard le verrier fameuse paul
ricard neuf l'étaient les camps pour moi
il m'a beaucoup inspiré qu'il admirait
beaucoup de gens aussi et surtout il
avait une phrase extraordinaire
10 est toujours un problème ça dure et
ça ce sur d'autres restent en euros pour
lui un problème c'est un tremplin dans
leur joint un problème pour les justes
nous obliger à avoir plus de créativité
plus d'inventivité pour être meilleur
plus un problème
il avait eu un très gros juste après
l'agréable ils veulent été modélisé il
rentre à les hydrique à marseille est là
pour nom en septembre 1940 fermetures
d'usinés pour le gouvernement de vichy à
des stocks pour arrêter de faire et fait
plus rien plus ils se retrouvent du jour
au lendemain comme chef d'entreprise
centre qui travaille en 48 heures il à
recaser tout le monde en disant qu'en
toute façon c'est pas le problème on n'a
pas de colonne est tous au chômage il
faut manger c'est l'appel il n'est pas
son camarde ils sont tous devenus masson
ouvriers agricoles ont gardé des vaches
sont pointés des fruits non seulement
ils ont passé toute la guerre 1 à s'en
sortir à s'entraîner mais il y ait
beaucoup de gens et à fournir du lait
des fruits et des légumes un gros
morceau du département est un petit peu
de telles que le carburant pour la
résistance l'entreprise a omis de 8 12
ans à venir de 40 à 51 ans il n'y a pas
eu une seule paire famille sentiers ils
ont tous travaillé ensemble ils ont tous
travaillé pour la communauté et ce genre
de photo je trouve qu'à longtemps qu'on
n'a pas vu un chef d'entreprise porté
par six équipes comme ça c'est plutôt ça
relève reconnu le domaine sportif
et c'est des jeunes entrepreneurs dans
la trêve par milo j'espère qu'un jour
vous aurez à vivre ça au sein d'une
entreprise
alors pourquoi je pars de mon grand père
parce que si on gaze de soie d'un
problème c'est un super tremplin pour
aller plus loin on va et 6.6 ckoi de
tremplin notre problème à nous
aujourd'hui
alors j'en ai fait les poissons tra qu'à
la faire ensemble si vous voulez bien
mais on y va changement climatique
surpopulation fin des ressources de
ressources énergétiques
je suis des grattoirs chômage maladie
cancer et ryder et debdeb encore là ono
en balance toute la journée
alors moi je crois a coûté une chose je
garde ma femme on voit tout à l'heure on
va arrêter de penser à tout ce qu'on
nous dit qu on va essayer de voir c'est
quoi notre réalité notre réalité c'est
ça le premier set fille de la planète
c'est là une photo c'est la première
moto qui a été la première à peu ta
maison commune où à l'époque moi j'étais
déjà prêt on était peut-être milliards
sur terre et tout à l'heure on a vu
maison et là il s'est passé plein jeu
s'est passé quelque chose d'abord à
naples après ça la terre on n'a pas ça
la planète
on a plus quand on s'est regardé sous
nos pieds autour de nous on a consentis
par aga dans l'air et puis on a oublié
qu'on faisait partie d'une grande
ça te fait vivre la nature la vie ça
comme vous voulez et puis on avance et
on a commencé à 24,5 toujours d'un
cancer espère améliorer sa qualité et
son faisait la photo aujourd'hui de
notre maison s'affrontent le reste ça
c'est notre réalité au beauty news
c'est peut-être vous avoir doigt les
pieds sur terre avec toute cette mémoire
du vivant 3.8 milliards d'années la
ville on a eu un petit peu plus tard si
vous mettez la distance de l'évolution
sur une année calendaire le 1er janvier
programmer les premières secondes les
appareils et nous on arrive le 31
décembre mais moins de 4 pièces
on n'est pas vraiment les premiers et
donc cette nouvelle réalité augmentée
nous a fait faire un petit peu de vue un
peu on était comme des êtres but logique
qu'on avait besoin de manger de respirer
bascharage et on a surtout brillé
qu'on n'était pas des sols on avait des
colocataires mais qu'il est plein de
dents sur cette planète ce que j'appelle
des voisins silencieux j'avais réussi un
championnat qui vont nous poser problème
encore prenez une forêt par exemple de
corps c'est magnifique
ils sont tous différents sont autant de
petits des grands des mâles des femelles
deux pas des malades ya pas de chômage
et patxi est le plus petit d'entre eux a
besoin du plus grand ils ces personnes
plus grand art de la forêt il peut
arriver on n'est plus rien s'il n'y a
pas de son petit champignon qui s'occupe
de lui
ils sont tous différents sont tous
ensemble ils font quelque chose de beau
et chacun a sa part de lumière
il se passe quelque chose sur la planète
en ce moment donc personne ne parle
un événement mondial c'est prodigieux
vraiment extraordinaire le papa
miniature par cet événement ce printemps
est-ce que vous avez déjà imaginé
organisé empruntant la voie je suis
maître après plusieurs parce que c'est
un train international
imaginez le nombre de vendeurs prend les
insectes les fleurs les oiseaux les
cabots les vers de terre et tout le
monde
pas de répétition et c'est chaque année
je joue on en sera là on a réussi
quelques leçons durabilité imaginez
l'incroyable le cycle de la zorn comme
commençons pas une ville comme la
broderie
fleurs d'octobre le j y la sphère de
pommes imaginez tous ces arbres qui font
plus de vaud avec les restes année
dernière plus de pollution
si ça c'est pas du recyclage imaginez
tout ce génie et surtout toute cette
organisation
c'est extraordinaire alors j'ai une
femme formidable aux états unis qui
s'appelle jeanine minutes je les aime
beaucoup
d'ailleurs le printemps c'est son idée
mais je trouve l'idée tellement belle
qu'elle voit pas moi je la partage et l
abîme étant relativement la nature y est
l'intelligence est dans la nature tout
ce qui existe encore aujourd'hui a
totalement réussi sa leçon de durabilité
c'est ce que fait si vous avez votre
leçon durabilité vous êtes plus leurs
employés milliards d'années vous avez le
temps de disparaître
en revanche pour survivre aujourd'hui
c'est bien que des champions a fait on
est entouré de championnant touré
premier battle et donc on a commencé à
s'intéresser à ça ça s'appelle le
biomimétisme facettes avec l'exemple le
plus connu
c'est le train japonais et le martin
pêcheur voilà la nouvelle relation
fameux nature propre char ce train
faisait beaucoup de bruit il avait là
des trains normal à 1000 années 30 il
faisait beaucoup de bruit
il se trouve que l'ingénieur était ce
train était un amateur d'oiseaux à
border que mondiale de la terre il avait
remarqué ça regardez ce matin des chars
un flash à une goûte pas une ride
3.8 milliards d'années il montre en
trois nuits mais quand même s'il se pose
après pêcheurs n'avaient pas réussi un
match incroyable rentrer dans l'aube
entre morts de faim se ferait pas du
poisson après le cake ou alors ça c'est
un peu le principe sur les formes on
peut s'inspirer vous allez voir que les
éoliennes ressort des nageurs de
baleines vous allez le velcro c'est
arrivé comme ça le yuan avait marre
d'avoir des chansons ne pardonnent sur
ses chaussettes il invente un peu grosse
aujourd'hui on va plus loin pour
s'inspirer des procédés thermiques ma
vingtaine a conditionné et termite à toi
que longtemps et puis on va même encore
plus loin on commence à se dire que les
écosystèmes
ça peut faire de l'écologie industrielle
après tout venue des chefs venus voter
si ce peut être la ressource du voisin
dans la nature y est pathétique et si ça
tout totalement humains on est arrivé
dernier est un peu pression que
n'importe quoi parce que quand on servir
l'école de la vie en tête des chèvres
ses propres yeux donc on est parti là
dessus et puis après vous dit révoltée
et d'industrie le management
mais les prairies sauvage tonnes des
maisons de finance à wall street
l'épreuve est sauvage c'est
extraordinaire c'est tout le temps en
production il peut faire du vent du
froid de la neige il ya 30 allemand
nombreux autres jeux brissart ans une
excellente n'êtes pas d'un destin
sauvage qui a toujours dit qu'ils s'en
sortent par les autres aujourd'hui on
s'inspire de sa conjointe des
portefeuilles boursiers
la nature ne maximisent jamais la nature
optimise la nature le terrien seule la
nature est en interaction et touchant
sans visite libre sassou pertinente est
ça je sais qu'on a eu les petites leçons
nourriture juste avant moi mais sainte
une approche de l'agriculture
c'est un sujet probablement on a tous
entendu que de toute façon on pourrait
pas être surpris trop nombreux on
n'allait pas avoir assez à manger du lot
tout le monde a cette fois d'après la
permaculture c'est un jardin produit
toute l'année et on a des bonnes choses
formidables quand vous mettez plusieurs
distractions ensemble quand vous
associez les différences en fait ces
espèces valeur et devient être
totalement productive
aujourd'hui sur sur 1000 mètres carrés
donc 625 à peu près le cultiver on
affirme ouvrir cinq familles
imaginez que depuis deux mille ans on
arrive à terme et ce destin sur des
grandes surfaces en fait c'est la taille
du tracteur que j'oblige régit notre
notre agriculture mais elle a maintenu
la trêve dimension est scellé seule la
première fois de ma vie j'ai entendu un
mot extraordinaire le tour dans une
conférence sur la ma culture j'ai
entendu quelqu'un dire nous aggravons
les sols ne savais pas qu'on pouvait
parler positivement de la dégradation
des phoques se voyait ça vous pouvez
partir du muc souviendra pas vous pouvez
faire pousser la vie la nature partout
et notamment sa femme un projet fou ça
va bientôt arrêter si tu as une barbe
noire et cheveux courts pourra mettre un
fermier ce qu'on ait besoin de boire des
canons des frigos parce qu'on a besoin
de déchirer la terre
on a besoin de labourer et cela besoin
de tout ce qu'un vol pour faire tout
simplement un joli un joli potager un
vrai talent alors on a aussi oublié
qu'on n'était pas tout seul nous voisins
silencieux que le voisin actifs ou si
c'était une petite parabole je voulais
raconter qu'elle ait permis de raconter
après c'est l'histoire d'un agriculteur
japonais et une petite surface de riz et
il faisait que du riz avait beaucoup
d'un grand petit il était malade pour de
transporter tout cela est de manger tout
ça et sa férocité malades comme ils
étaient tous les deux mal à taux sur les
conseils de ses médecins et ses amis il
arrête un peu tous ces produits et ils
découvrent le biologique a révélé qu'une
taupe est logique mais voulant faire du
public parce que l'autre dit que toutes
ces plantes baba de beaucoup en train
avec lorie et pouvait pas de ramasser
alors en désespoir de cause il s'est dit
mais quand j'étais enfant il y avait des
quinze comédiens donc c'est du pipeau
paru l'année indique à damas et dix à
vingt plusieurs élus d'assister au bien
être et de la nature ce que nous
appelons aujourd'hui des services
écosystémiques vous mettez le canal
cultive à manger tout ce qui m'a j'ai
les pieds d'avis et parasites petite
enquête et c'est que le canard mardi
repli va être capable de faire le tri
manger toutes les espèces que vous
n'avez pas me garder
et puis au bout du compte c'est d'avoir
du canard de rydia murs gris murs et
comme en plus titré le niveau cette
envie cette visite et ça autorise en
fait la nature nous apprend à faire de
moins en mieux pour reprendre
l'expression d'un de philo balle je sais
qu'on nous a dit craig wright mission
d'aider plus mais on peut travailler
autrement
pokernews alors ça c'est le dernier
exemple la manquons beaucoup de progrès
vous entendez bien sûr que les océans se
vident est un petit peu vrai la pêche
n'a pas inventé dans les foyers quarante
mille ans on n'a jamais changé d'avis
sur la pêche non pas celui apprendre
apprendre apprendre à prendre c'est un
bien commun humanité à la mesure de se
nourrir de poissons et nous on a mis
toute notre intelligence 1
des appuis aux destinataires retard on
est de plus en plus malade et on pêche
de moins en moins et a manqué quelque
chose dans ce film et vous allez d'après
deux tiers des poissons qui vont mourir
étouffé qui ne vont pas arriver sur une
assiette quelque part quel gâchis
et dans ce film vous avez des femelles
poison qui ont des millions d'oeuvres
temps dans l'ordre du million dire qu'on
va manger des poissons qui aurait pu
créer des millions de poissons
est-ce que c'est pas un peu idiot est ce
que la nature et des choses aussi
absurde
alors je vous racontais notre façon de
pêcher mais jude law chili lé des gens
qui feront via l'arrivée vous savez
qu'on est sur mon revers et la mi
journée pour récupérer une femelle ou
récupérer des petits hommes poissons les
femelles vous avez droit de la moche et
ça c'est quand même été des millions de
poissons ou les élever et puis vous les
relâcher en mer
et puis vont nourrir le reste de la
communauté toujours donner à nos
communautés
et puis quand ils sont grands et qu'ils
on ne peut pas leur tour ils reviennent
frapper à la porte de la pêcherie pas ne
pas de bateau n'y a pas de filet elle
vous nourrissez pas le scinder stories
tout seul on peut aussi péché comme ça
en fait la nature de raconte les
solutions il faut juste apprendre ça
c'est landreau de travail signés des
embiez la champagne
l'équipe est formidable avec de
l'institut océanographique paul ricard
comme mon grand père a créé en 66 quand
ils agressaient pour un prêteur ce
monsieur qui fait du paty 6 mai à
s'intéresser à la scénographie ce
n'était pas évident mais il se trouve
qu'il adorait la mer il avait compris
qu'il fallait commencer un peu à
s'occuper autrement et si un jour vous
voulez savoir comment quelque chose là
la meilleure façon de savoir comment
marche quelque chose s'il décide de
réparer conséquences et ne pouvait pas
réparer quelque chose si vous ne savez
pas comment ça marche et c'est ce qu'a
fait cette équipe extraordinaire c'est
une vieille photo mais je voulais leur
rendre hommage c'est une journée avait
lieu à l'époque ses débuts des marées
noires
et quand on nettoyé une marée noire est
un employé des produits très toxiques
lorsque propre mais c'est mort en fait
ils ont juste observer ce que devaient
la nature comment la nature des graves
et les hydrocarbures nous en découvertes
et des bactéries les plus loin c'est le
canard la canicule et du coup ils ont
mis au produit et ont mis au point un
produit qui dégradent et marion à tous
ces exemples c'est pour vous dire que il
faut pas perdre de vue que nous sommes
dans une réalité biologique même si nous
avons la capacité intellectuelle
d'imaginer d'autres réalités
pourtant sur une planète comme sagesse
valence qui a réussi tous ces défis qui
en plus âgés de rosine et de nous donner
tous ces savoirs au pop in health est un
grand pote équipe de consultants qui ne
manque pas de royalties et surtout parce
que je voudrais c'est que ce magnifique
cette magnifique connaissance qu'est
comme un grand livre dont on a franchi
les pages les eaux commencent à dire
maintenant je voudrais que ce grand
livre où ils apprennent à venir votre
enfant puisque c'est après tout la terre
et pour eux autant leur donner dès
maintenant la capacité de comprendre
qu'ils sont dans une réalité
bienveillante et que l'histoire avait
tout - ou si ce n'est qu'un conte de
fées